taylor swift is headed for halftime but  not the one you think  i'm so excited about this  [Music]  has learned the look what you made me do  singer will perform at the college  football national championship in  atlanta this january our source says  quote espn has her booked for the event  and has a massive deal to release new  music from reputation through its  college football coverage this season  that makes sense taylor debuted her  latest track ready for it on saturday  during abc and espn's coverage of the  alabama florida state game  et's source adds that this was a  no-brainer for taylor she actually can't  do super bowl halftime because it's  sponsored by pepsi and she has that  coca-cola endorsement deal quote follow  the money taylor's sponsors at ups and  atm t are two of the biggest ncaa  football advertisers on espn  i don't understand how you can not  fangirl about that e.t did reach out to  reps for comment on this and for now  espn is denying the news  [Music]